so the institution for social and policy
studies has a three-fold mission we want
to do high quality social science
research we want to use that research to
shape policy and we want to shape also
the next generation of leaders in the
policy process we have the Center for
the Study of American politics it's
thinking about democracy and its
operation we also have the new center
for the study of health and finally
we're creating the new center for the
study of inequality that center headed
by veselo Weaver will be focused on
inequality and its relationship to
American governance my aim in bringing
us here is simple to explore the
prospects and dimensions of minority
flourishing in the United States so that
we can embark on a project of American
democracy and equality that reaches
beyond those formal protections that
were bequeathed to us by the Civil
Rights Act the Voting Rights Act the
Fair Housing Act and others we're at a
moment of both sustained impressive
cultural progress and yet yawning
substantive gaps we may not all agree on
the right questions to ask for the right
variables to plug into our regression
analyses or even how high the hurdles
are but at least I hope we can agree on
that that that project is a worthy one
quiet crisis of people who don't have
bank accounts who pay too much for
whatever they do purchase who are really
constrained in terms of access to credit
and what the consequences of that are
and so here again economic freedom is
not economic justice the most notable
feature of American politics over the
last generation is that in the face of
rising inequality we haven't seen that
much of a government response that's not
because Americans don't care about it
middle-class Americans are very
concerned about the sense of the
American Dream is slipping away but they
have very little faith in the ability of
our public leaders to address the
problem and it's precisely political
scientists and other social scientists
who can step back from the debates of
the moment and think about this
relationship among political
institutions the processes that
produce public policy and the real world
consequences of those policies it's
precisely those social scientists who
should be engaged in the debate about
how our political institutions and
public policies should be reformed
progressives have rightfully spent a
tremendous amount of time arguing for d
car serration that effort has to shift
to really focus on investment and
integration before people have settled
on a particular research agenda
collected the data gone out gotten the
grant funding started writing papers
presenting at conferences before any of
that happens I want them to put their
biggest boldest idea down in four pages
are less distill it for a broad audience
we as a team of six you know half a
dozen researchers vet these and talk
about them and go back and forth on them
and examine the possibilities then we
begin to talk about okay you know what
this kind of data is the data that we
need to go collect these are the people
we need to go talk to these are the
archives that would be helpful here then
we go out and we do the research we
actually have multiple kinds of
interactive inequalities depending on
who we are where we are where we live we
all may experience some form of
inequality compared to someone else or
some other group but it could be vastly
different the goal is to produce
research that policymakers journalists
civic organizations can use in their
activities to give them a knowledge base
so that when they produce policy when
they debate ideas they've got something
there that is my real I ideal for the
center that is my I can go home now goal
is to is to have it produce something
that means graduate students can
in their careers that means we have a
better handle on how this is being
experienced in American communities that
means that it's got a lifeblood beyond
just a day in the center